[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless that's
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
[Applause]
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker listen i did not kill
mysterio the drones did the drones that
are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
like how do you tell someone that you're
spider-man
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
so peter
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please we saved half the
universe together i think we're beyond
you calling me sir okay stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i
the won't world is about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mgm's gonna forget about everything
we've ever been through stop tampering
with the spell oh my god ned he's my
best friend my aunt may should really
stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free
you have got to get control of your
aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can break it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
cletus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
let you eat everybody
i promise oh yeah
eddie
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
[Music]
throughout my life
the ten rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family
you are your mother
and whether you like it or not
you are also your father
i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
glad i was right
here's just a criminal
who murders people
be careful how you speak to me boy
start a new life
but i could never
escape his shadow
my son
you can't run from your past
[Applause]
is this what you wanted
got this
thank you
[Music]
from your secret friends
[Music]
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
[Music]
you're becoming quiet celebrity
[Music]
why is he writing to you
if you
are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
this guy's crazy
you're part of this too
oh my part of it
you'll see
[Music]
[Music]
five thousand years ago kondok was a
melting pot of cultures wealth power and
magic
yet most of us had nothing
except for the chains around our necks
conduct needed a hero
instead they got me
i did what needed to be done
and they imprisoned me for it
[Music]
now 5 000 years later
i'm free
and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
michael
i've known you since you were a child
you the gift
you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it
that's not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
it's happening i went from time
to feeling more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
it's an overpowering urge to consume
blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
got
michael
morbiel
doing the whole good guy thing huh
what's up
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you